j'étais petit je regardais la télévision
à l'époque sont en noir et blanc
il y avait trois émissions que j'adorais
par dessus tout et qui m'ont beaucoup
influencé finalement il y avait dit mme
dam dom daisy de galard il y avait les
raisins verts de jean christophe averty
et l'émission de benjamin castaldi et
l'émission de benjamin castaldi qui
s'appelle c'est que ça fait déjà
célébrités non il y avait une autre
émission qui s'appelait un égal 3
c'était jacques martin et jean yanne
voilà ah oui là respect ils font de vous
avec les faut rendre hommage à martin
parce que c'est une émission que lui
avait eu c'était c'est à lui qu'on avait
demandé bon et c'est lui qui m'a fait
venir
il a eu raison parce que c'est vachement
et enverra un bout tout à l'heure vous
ai vu le nombre de fiches que j'ai sur
vous c'est incroyable j'ai jamais autant
de fiches sur canal ne sont pas un livre
vous n'êtes pas sortir bien alors on va
commencer tout sud par la promo comme ça
ça sera fait 1
alors attention c'est comment on fait à
quelques petites mains comme les sourds
muets que ce soit qui commençait pas
avec les sons d'hiver ses jupes lundi
mène selon elle changé après a inventé
ce que vous voulez bien sûr surtout vous
attention 1 2 3 j
c'est bien bien
alors donc jean yanne vous publiez un
bouquin qui s'appelle le dictionnaire
des mots qui a que moi qui les connaît
déjà le titre vachement bien c'est chez
plon cdm ou que vous avez inventé vous
alors par exemple page 25 viennent non
mais j'ai noté comme ça quelques soins
qui vont bien faire et 25 à baluch riz
par exemple alors une baluch free c'est
une phrase stupide exemple la démocratie
s'arrête où commence la raison d'état
c'est qui ces deux plats secourable via
phrase ou le savez ce que c'est une
phrase ou leur nom oui j'ai lu
attentivement le livre de jean qui est
un maître que je vénère comme henri
salvador
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai que c'est la
deuxième fois que je vois respectueux
pour quelques mois ces réalités des
dieux vivants pour moi
donc continuez comme ça quand ça
commence comme ça on voit déjà les
chandeliers les mecs arrivent et noir
sapin 500 by nécro un peu c'est vraiment
tout le temps si à la fin il n'y a pas
un qui va prendre même si je serais vous
je m'inquiéterais jorian je t'admire et
même quand tu étais jeune donc rien à
voir avec la mort alors une fois zouli
tâche certes une phrase houle c'est un
vampire se nourrissant uniquement du
sont deux jeunes filles vierges et dont
l'espèce a complètement disparu pour
cette raison évidemment c'est une phrase
houle
alors après j'en ai encore ah oui j'en
ai un qui est drôle c'est inclus mieux
plutôt mou et pas très nets salue bien
ce que ça veut dire
le travail effectué par madame cresson
pendant son séjour à la commission de
bruxelles et a recruté stablement glu
mieux passé que des trucs comme ça c'est
des mots donc cédé moque d'eux l'a
inventé oui mais c'est les mots que j'ai
inventé après la définition
ah oui c'est ça sert vous avez commencé
je n'ai pas commencé à prendre des
définit un ponte des mots puis à
chercher ce que ça voulait dire
j'essaie des définitions qui après j'ai
cherché quelques mots qui correspondent
le plus à ça alors par exemple il ya it
l'opel l'article open c'est une réunion
de personnalités désignées par l'état
pourrait assumer dans l'audiovisuel des
fonctions bien au dessus de leurs
compétences ce qui gêne considérablement
le travail qu'ils ont qualifiée alors
vise personne évidemment enfin c'est
assez on voit tout de suite de qui il
s'agit i gr big aussi alors il rabique
bon à rien granic de tout le service
public la télévision française peut se
vanter de posséder le plus grand nombre
d'y graver hic si vous voulez ya un fond
de vérité tout les toutes les dix ou
quinze définition il y en a une de
bonnes séquences et des mots qui risque
d'être d'être employé ça j'espère qu'ils
vont être employés
ça m'est jamais arrivé de faire quoi que
ce soit qui ne soit repris un jour ou
l'autre par un homme politique
pidoux avait dit tout le monde il est
beau tout le monde il est gentil
et il y avait comme ça il ya des tas de
trucs qui sont entrés dans la dans la
langue y arrive est interdit d'interdire
quand même jorian a inventé en 68 tout
le monde croit que c'est des étudiants
du quartier latin qui l'ont inventé
c'est vous qui l'avez inventé un matin
sur rtl il est interdit d'interdire qui
est devenu un tout le monde croit que ça
a été fait par des étudiants gauchistes
six mois qu'il ya des gens comme vous
qui rétablisse la vérité qui agit là
pour ça ça m'a coûté assez cher oui
c'est vrai c'est assez de toi crs ss et
c'est pas de moi moi j'ai inventé le
peuple aura ta peau sur les pavés les
frites non dieu est grand allah et aux
enzymes
alors si vous dites que c'est un
dictionnaire qui contrairement aux
autres puissent être ouvert à n'importe
quelle page pour y trouver ce qu'on
cherche pas oui parce qu'il a été écrit
comme ça
ouais à partir du moment où il a été
écrit il sans sans plan et au fur et à
mesure j'ai été dans des endroits où je
pouvais pas écrire des choses très très
compliqué j'avais seulement des petites
fiches et j'écrivais des petites notes
pour moi des fois j'ai éclaté de rire
j'étais contente je n'en trouvais une
bonne alors j'étais content et je pense
que les gens doivent le lire comme ça et
les l'idéal c'est de le mettre dans les
toilettes
un avis que tout le monde va faire un
service qui a été écrit dans l'est dans
les avions effectivement
vous voyagez beaucoup en fait non quand
vous dites à un moment page 79 les
toilettes des avions d'air france sont
abyss conique
c'est à dire quoi visco ni salle salle
voilà depuis une façon générale tout ce
qui est sûr air france est raté alors il
ya les toilettes qui sont mal nettoyé
les hôtesses de l'air qui sont des
grands mères de lente et les et les
plateaux-repas d'où son adorable
éventuellement renoncer au fait de te
faire surclasser vous avez le goût des
voyages vous c'est marrant c'est un truc
c'est vraiment votre passion non mais
ouais mais vous dites ya une sensation
extraordinaire c'est dans un avion
finalement puis à un moment il ya le
pilote qui lie la votre droite c'est le
mont kenya votre gauche c'est l'île
maurice puis c'est vrai que c'est
plaisant
jeudi je regarde toujours mal et je suis
pas du tout blasé je regarde toujours
par la main là par le hublot qui est
tout à fait non il y en a une ou deux
qu'ils se défendent pas sur les attaques
et venir c'est joey starr il y avait
dans le temps avec les kaizer franz une
espèce de d'habitude de l'accord tacite
de joutes sur les lignes brésilienne
l'international justement si c'est pas
le steward qui est déguisé
déjà première révélation de la soirée
jean yanne ne s'appelle pas jorian
jorian s'appelle jean gougy nous a bien
fait de changer en même temps mais
pendant mon enfance il ya eu beaucoup de
d'utilisation un peu annexes et décalé
demanderait et pourquoi yann c'est mon
prénom yann parce que je suis d'origine
bretonne gouhier ça veut dire petit
marrant que c'est joli tout ça alors
vous dites que vous êtes né donc j'étais
en 33 on peut le dire et vous dites
alors quand on est né en 33 ans et tous
farsi1 il y avait d'abord tous les ans
un examen parce que le certif c'était en
deux parties le diplôme d'études
primaires en deux parties le brevet
élémentaire le bepc fameux pc on de
parricide on appelait les classes
nouvelles c'est dire que jusqu'à la
guerre de vingt noms quand on est en
train de toi on a sept ans à l'arrière à
ce qu'on commence à aller vraiment ne au
collège à 10 ans aux gens et là c'était
les classes nouvelles après la guerre
donc on essayait tout en deux parties
voilà force et en deux parties et le
service militaire faut dire qu'à
l'époque c'était 28 mois quand même à 32
c'est terrible il ya de la prison là
dedans
un peu de placards ya quand même un nom
il ya eu un petit peu de prison mais pas
longtemps parce que comme c'était la
guerre d'algérie on m'avait mis en
prison à la caserne duplex et la prison
était un peu dans mon sous-sol et moi je
me trompe je me pensais au soupirail je
disais je suis arabe et atom torture la
coupe des nations
alors les gens aient protesté avec
torture et les arabes
là non mais la lgv entre excuses et
bientôt breton bien alors votre père
était ébéniste et ensuite lithographe
abord little
c'est un point de vue mais c'est bien
heureusement que vous êtes là comme ça
se fait corriger mais de niche mais il
faisait des lithos de benjamin rabier ça
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai juste bon ou
bonne question
benjamin rabier c'est le type qui a
dessiné la vache qui rit quand même
c'est pas un truc avec c'est vrai oui
votre mère était couturière
oui chez madeleine vionnet et chez
lanvin
oui juste vous allez au lycée chaptal
bien collège turgot lycée chaptal c'est
bien voir s'ils connaissent à vis de
l'école de journalisme vous avez été
virés vous êtes parti non je suis j'ai
pas été jusqu'à la fin j'ai pas été viré
je suis pas parti c'est à dire que les
deux premières années c'était l'école
normale à partir de la troisième année
c'était les techniques de la presse dont
classe amende était un peu l'imprimerie
l'école estienne tout ça est servi et
bien de journalistes mais pas un gamer
la semaine et alors là après la guerre
vous rencontrez quelqu'un qui s'appelle
bob du parc à saint germain il s'appelle
bob du pack de mars nous lie du gab et
de toy non une ancre jetée pas cette
place sur la fiche pour tous marqués
dans ce qui est génial c'est que là vous
faites du commence à faire du cabaret et
vous faites un cabaret rue de rivoli
d'histoire insensé qui s'appelle
l'académie des vins blancs a expliqué
nous parce que là il y avait des gens
qui venaient
les cartes non c'était quand il y avait
un cabaret qui était rue de rivoli qui
doit s'appeler le slow club maintenant
qui est au 2e et 2e étages en sous sol
et le pâton ils appâtent one avait
trouvé un truc c'est qu'il y avait des
cars qui faisait la tournée des grands
ducs à paris dans l'ouest au lido à
pigalle et il fallait une cave saint
germain des prés mais j'étais très dur
de se garer à saint-germain-des-prés
c'était beaucoup plus facile de se garer
à rue de rivoli et comme les touristes
n'y voyait que du feu
les cars arrivaient à saint germain des
prés et nous on avait fait un spectacle
qui était qu'ils n'avaient pas de début
qu'ils n'avaient pas de faim savait pas
d'importance puisque quand le car arrive
et en os ont sonné les types descendait
le spectacle était commencée et au bout
de quelques temps le guide leur disais
bon bah c'est terminé pour partir il
partait avant que ce soit fini
et alors il fallait vraiment accrédités
saint-germain dépassé à que vous en
faites vous jouiez le temps oui dans
quelle était la turista tél après direct
dix ans dans l'izoard et et d'une
semaine et alors on avait on a géré un
moment mais il faut quand même que ce
soit plus saint germain des prés alors
on a trouvé un mec qui ressemblait à
sartre et on l'a mis dans un coin avec
bloch il l'écrivait des images ça c'est
jean paul sartre qui avait consacré à
fait josiane entre dans le show business
est engagé aux trois bonnets par jacques
canetti après un service militaire et la
fourgonnette que vous avez une bonne
gage vous étiez chargé du costume sous
lion c'est vrai ça c'est pas vrai c'est
un flux c'est pas vrai le mec qui fait
les fiches c'est moi qui te fais mes
fesses mais c'est vrai c'est moi qui
fais mes filles simplement vous avez dû
déclarer vous avez vu les gars et un
jour un jeu où vous étiez jeunes
s'étaient enchaînés j'avais dû le dire
le service militaire je faisais le
costume du loup alors j'étais jeune j'ai
fait mon service militaire dont pas la
première partie phase militaire au
service historique de l'armée
oui mais quand on est au service
historique de l'armée on n'écrit pas
forcément l'histoire des jupons
l'histoire du vêtement souvient qu'il
n'était pas fou de l'armée non j'étais
au service heures et d'armer ou aux
classes est toutes les choses qui
concerne l armée et toutes mes shows
militaire une gaminerie ça nous
permettait de continuer à vous occuper
de vos activités sociales des loisirs
bon alors là c'est l'époque des cabarets
alors ça dit plus rien à personne
aujourd'hui les cabarets l'amiral club
55 des trucs plus personne ne sait ce
que c est alors à l'époque bas vous
faites vous rencontrer jacques martin
fait cette émission mythique qui
s'appelle un égal 3 on va voir
d'ailleurs un sketch que j'oserais dire
avancer que j'ai reçu un email d'un
dénommé laurent picone qui est un
français qui habitent en hollande et qui
me dit ma femme et moi on a décidé de
faire un enfant
et de l'appeler serge et quand l'enfant
sera né en lui offrira un chien et on
l'appellera manier tout
[Applaudissements]
tu verras ce que tu voudras fredo mais
dans cette année gros de beethoven
on sent encore vachement n'influence de
mozart pour dire que c'est la période
charnière de l'évolution beethovénienne
je suis d'accord avec toi mais c'est
plus sensible dans l'allée grande dans
l'adhésion en filigrane par le fait
c'est sa deuxième manière à beethoven
c'est du bac
il se dit pas ce produit vers l'ouest
c'est qu'ils jouent le
c'est françois janvier ouais ça vraiment
pas de cinq voitures connaît pas la
taille c'est adrian flandin son bien il
joue plus délié dans les aigus samedi
dernier jeu nous vendait les mômes à
fallou des invalides pour entendre
duprat je viens du croyant est la mieux
de bien du froid ils veulent quoi moi je
trouve qu'il a une bonne persistance
rythme et doit les tuer
sincèrement il joue bien mais il sait
pas se servir de la deuxième viole de
gambe sade et paul allard enregistra
sont au dessus mais quand il a un bon
instrument comment qui se défend je vais
lire un peu qui
[Musique]
est sacrée
mais guy gilbert je vais jouer tu sais
ce que c'est tu ferais tu mens lire est
un peu tôt ouais je suis le roseau de
rester dans le désert de la chrétienté
je suis là triste fleurs flétri sous le
poids des païens je suis la colombe qui
chante dans la chapelle du créateur je
suis le cri d'amour de l'occident
[Musique]
on me dit tu sais mais j'ai choisi le
passage le plus mince couche tard
lorsque je vois plus clair à lui-même
julien gauthier y avait une cyborg reply
a aussi permis de conduire qui est très
connu qui est en latin et que tout le
monde connaît le permis de conduire est
alors en 64 il ya eu un sketch
alors là vous avez une histoire terrible
c'est un sketch les napoléon qui faisait
une course cycliste avec ses généraux un
et c'est lui qui vous a fait virer ceux
là ou non non non celui qui nous a fait
virer non non celui qui nous a fait
virer c'est une
dans ce cas cheese passé dans une église
est où
moi j'étais en train de mettre des
fleurs sur l'autel et puis martin entre
en moto rozier c'est moi qui est correct
et martin me déshabillait et ils me le
faisaient du gringue ils baissaient
massa l'opel agila loin de là ça a été
dur et puis un autre truc aussi où je
faisais choix de zaire et où jouer
bientôt poule alors là ça n'est plus
tellement aujourd'hui
alors voilà donc ça donc moi ça a été
pour moi fondateur je pense pas beaucoup
de gens aussi et en 65 vous rencontrer
claude chabrol et vous faites des films
très important vous fait le boucher la
ligne de démarcation que la bête meure
en faction des films très important
godard vous faites week end il un film
aussi très important et puis après ça
s'est un petit peu gâté mais vous dites
tout le monde croit que j'ai joué des
navets puis après les bons films en fait
vous allez commencer par les bons films
vos j'ai commencéà sur des bons si j'ai
fait des navets après ouais c'est ça
mais j'ai fait les navets avec une
certaine volupté
c'est pas parce que m a pas engagés dans
des banques en est la preuve
je trouvais ça bien de faire des films
séries qui après les navettes a refait
des bons films algériens julien sans
arrêt vous savez il ya eu à cette époque
là les
les comiques faisait très peu de temps
dans les films d'harry cole faisait une
demi-journée dans nos fans et ça
suffisait pas ce que les gens allez le
voir il entendait hour cailloux les gens
étaient ravis
alors tous les tous les gens qui
faisaient des films voulait avoir au
moins une demi-journée ou une journée
d'alcool et moi j'étais avec francis
blanche et nous on nous mettait tout le
temps dans le fond il y avait des scènes
qui se passait dans les films n'importe
n'importe où et nous on parlait et on
faisait les métèques on était au bar et
on parlait et alors le metteur en scène
alizés alesi parlez parlez entre vous
alors on parlait alors bon quand on
savait plus quoi dire on avait un code
et on disait je suis catholique comme
vous c'était le cas la france il y là je
suis fatigué hier j'ai mangé traque
mondiale est très difficile et puis je
suis rentré tard la maison et puis moi
je vais vous dire je suis catholique
comme vous alors je savais qu'ils
diraient plus rien et tu savais que
j'enchaîne alors jeu mais qu'est-ce qui
vous rapporte la russie et de
plaisanterie facile
moi aussi je jusqu'à ce que je ne
supporte plus rien et moi aussi je suis
ta télécoms a vu le temps de redonner
cherché pendant six à là c'est un truc
qu'on trouvera pas parce qu'évidemment
ça a été foutu à poubelles mais c'est la
même chose s'il ya six à huit prises et
a eu un prix différent est versée mais
jamais une chose est ce que vous croyez
vous êtes un grand acteur s couperet qui
est un grand acteur parce que vous
prenez ça par dessus la jambe
non non pas du tout je dame en jeu
je serai pas dire surtout à la
télévision française devant des
milliards de gens dans le monde qui
parle français et pas si bien dire que
je suis un grand acteur jeudi si c'est
le mot sexe est un contact merci merci
beaucoup je mange dit simplement je suis
un acteur plausible c'est dire je n'ai
jamais fait une chose qui me paraissent
pas plausible un don si on me demande de
faire un vétérinaire
je connais les vétérinaires qu'on ma
tête mon allure mon gouvernement je peux
faire un vétérinaire
si on me demande de faire un camion que
les camionneurs comme mon allure mon
comportement je peux conduire un camion
si on me demande de faire un pianiste
romantique avec george sand là je fais
pas c'est plutôt que je peux pas faire
l'aiglon alors quand vous avez le prix à
cannes le prix d'interprétation pour pia
là pour nous ne vieillirons pas ensemble
je me remarquable vous alors tout le
monde vous admire tout le monde chante
vos louanges et vous vous dites montre
il suffisait que je baisse les yeux pour
voir leur triste jeu baisser les yeux
pour regarder mon texte ont fait l'essai
pense-bête partout dans la voiture et
tout le monde crier au génie
oui mais je peux plus le faire parce que
je vois plus clair alors avant je
pouvais baisser les lieux lire mon texte
en faux cul et on disait il est triste
maintenant si je dis tu sais j'ai de la
peine bien mais comme nous
il ya un mec était comme mousse était le
chancelier adenauer
parce que lui c'est pareil il vous dit
on a toujours cru que tu es vachement
sérieux à l'anneau vert avait une
blessure était chancelier allemand après
la guerre c'est le premier chancelier
allemand alors il a une blessure de
guerre qui lui a coupé les zygomatiques
et les zygomatiques ils sont de chaque
côté du stage je peux comment il a pu
prendre un éclat d'obus double qui lui a
coupé les deux mais ils n'auraient pas
ils pouvaient pas faire autrement
il ya un mec qui fait ça mieux que moi
dans le dallas dans la lecture des des
textes c'est brando ouais bon dos ils
touchent pas une bille il va lui connaît
jamais son texte quand il l'a fait
apocalypse now
il devait sortir d'une grotte et on
pouvait la scène était filmée d'un
bateau qui était sur la rivière donc on
pouvait paraître un prompteur on pouvait
pas mettre quelque chose pour qu'ils
lisent
alors on a dû mettre son texte de
l'autre côté de la rivière il a fallu
mettre un texte de 1 mètre de haut
quelle qu'elle soit un panneau
gigantesque son texte à la bombe et vous
vous dites plus je souris plus généreux
triste je défends vous dis souris sourit
c'est vrai on a tout le temps envie de
vous dire pourquoi faisait pas l'air
content souriez souriez pour voir ja
[Applaudissements]
dans vos buts a finalement que le
tracteur bah oui c'est comme un
cordonnier qui a pris à réparer des
chaussures depuis l'âge de 19 ans et qui
connaît bien son métier on lui demande
pas d'être passionné quoi on a le
sentiment vous faites ça comme ça bon en
fait très très bien mais avec une espèce
de distance je crois que c'est le
principe même du
du bon travail c'est à dire que on n'a
jamais où il ya pas de ce quart de la
plomberie
non on comprenait il n'y a pas de ya pas
de gens qui se félicite corporatives
mans à longueur de journée comme nous
mais bon je sais que ça vous a beaucoup
touché d'avoir le 7 d'or puisque j'ai vu
des larmes couler sur vos jours mais bon
vous rendez compte qu'il y avait les
sept d'heures de la pâtisserie c'est
comme les camionneurs ça serait comme
les routiers et que nous y viendrez
pleurer
et alors là on continue la vie de jean
yanne qui est passionnante
les gens
[Applaudissements]
et
alors au delà de cette mélodie qu'on
connaît tous il faut savoir que tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde était
gentil était le premier film anti pub
antiste c'était de consommation anti
radios commerciales
les mecs il vous fait des bd des années
avec dédé des années 60 absolument c'est
à dire que les mecs ils bouffaient enfin
vous avez vu le film là les mecs film
culte il vous fait des concerts j'étais
couvert de boutons à la radio le mâle 20
ouais alors aujourd'hui un mouvement
vous savez ça qui s'appelle les casseurs
de pub vous connaissez les casseurs de
pub un nom
les casseurs de pub c'est un mouvement
de résistance à l'agression publicitaire
iad journée sans un char et aujourd'hui
c'est le 25e rang aujourd'hui j'étais la
journée sans achat
aujourd'hui c'était pour acheter
aujourd'hui ils ont fait un acte
criminel parce que c'était aujourd'hui
la journée sans achat et il a dû se
poser des [ __ ] et est donc la publicité
il dit ça ramène l'être humain au rang
de produit 10 la pub bestial is la pub
c'est du totalitarisme soft vous pensez
ça aussi nom de temps en temps la pub
est d'abord rigolote qui est vrai il ya
des trains marrante et puis ça montre
simplement qu'il ya des gens qui ont des
idées de temps en temps c'est irritant
parce que l'on ment et là on le sait
comment il c'est embêtant parce que la
plupart du temps on ment pour les
produits pas chers donc on ment aux
petites gens honnêtes si le mec il dit
mais c'est de la publicité pour une robe
du soir à 80 mille balles et qui dit
regardez comme ce serait super 16 août
germaine prince indien bjp brodé bon bah
ça va venir mais c'est surtout les
petits produits quand les petites des
petites choses qui risque d'avoir les
grands-mères et ça c'est pas ça c'est
pas très bien cela dit la pub ça permet
à plein de gens de faire le ce qui
n'existe plus maintenant c'est le court
métrage
ouais parce que dans le cinéma il ya
plus beaucoup de courts métrages on perd
quand c'est le cas c'est une bonne école
parce qu'il faut être efficace
croyez vous encore qu'une croissance
infinie est possible sur une planète où
les ressources sont limitées
le samedi 25 novembre c'est la journée
sans achat alors faites un geste pour la
terre
arrêtez d'acheter voilà c'était
aujourd'hui voilà le journal donc
casseurs de pub existe des états unis
s'appelle adbusters
il ya tout un mouvement comme ça de
citoyens contre la pilosité une journée
sans pognon aussi vrai ça serait drôle
alors vous êtes quand même très branché
pognon dont on allait chercher plancher
poney on a l'impression quand même que
vous avez comme ça toute votre vie
j'avais un peu couru après l'argent
regardez d'édicter catholique comme les
non bien sûr que je suis moche et pognon
et c'est comme laisser comme les rôles
c'est vrai on dit par exemple
moi j'ai dit ça plusieurs fois je dis je
on reçoit sur son scénario on m'a dit
vous serez en costume de lin blanc sur
une plage avec une très belle jeune
fille qui va vous servir des pompes et
puis un mec qui va vous éventé derrière
et vous allez poser votre main d'un sac
de loukoums et l'automation à ça bon
c'est plus un verbe que d'aller tourner
germinal dans le
dans les corps donc les forêts forcément
c'est plus agréable de gagner de
l'argent qui est pas en avoir
c'est plus agréable dans des beaux
endroits que dans des endroits pour ie
c'est plus agréable de bien manger comme
dangers de la mer et a à ce propos de
reparler d'une compagnie aérienne
alors vous êtes vous êtes un peu ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un bobo c'est
ce que c'est un bobo c'est un bourgeois
bohème ça c'est des gens qui ont des
idées de gauche et qui aime bien le
confort de droite web riches sinon mais
j'ai pas d'idée de gauche
ah bon armand vous disiez que vous aviez
des idées de gauche s'ils avaient des
idées un peu gauche maintenant presque
avant avant quand même il disait j'ai
décidé maintenant non non je suis dire
qu'à une certaine époque les idées de
gauche c'était facile à déterminer
tandis que maintenant les 10 et du
gauche quelle différence il ya entre
didier gauche et les centristes ont une
économie de marché 20 dont il saura tout
sur la mondialisation
alors vous êtes un jeune papa vous avez
quel âge il à votre enfant de neuf ans
neuf ans vous avez changé d'avis depuis
les années 70 mais j'ai retrouvé une
déclaration sur les enfants étaient
terribles les enfants je les déteste
réussir un mariage c'est difficile mais
si on le rate ça peut s'arranger un
enfant raté ça ne s'arrête jamais si
j'en avais eu j'aurais pas la patience
de m'en occuper et si des fois j'avais
la patience celui inculte courait que
des notions qui ferait lui un malheureux
en ait eu un qui maintenant est grand il
ne m'en suis pas occupé beaucoup et
occupe maintenant nos rayons sont faire
les enfants quand on est vieux
d'abord parce qu'on y en a pas longtemps
c'est entendre et jaune quand on a
besoin
where vivent bien c'est vraiment par bus
et embêté par des mots mais c'est faux
quand on est vieux on a le temps de s'en
occuper
vas-y on pouponne c'est bien vous avez
une vraie philosophie les ducs ont fais
tout moi vous pensez quoi jean yanne de
jean pierre bacri parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu votre
successeur dans la non il a un côté vous
avez comme vous voyez là cette espèce de
jeu parce qu'il a le même humour que
vous m'ont tous les cas il fait scruté
comme ça complètement oui ben oui oui le
prison trois ours mal léché oui mais
c'est ça ouais tu vous en faites votre
grand plaisir c'est de bouffer à poil
tout seul dans la cuisine non ça dépend
un peu beauf et hapoel avec quelqu'un
d'autre je dis ici on lui arrive d'être
annonce bien léché aussi c'est vrai que
là les la solitude n'est ce pas est un
taux qui m'a toujours épaté quand j'ai
vu des bons peut-être qu'il ya des gens
malheureux et qui sont encore plus
malheureux parce qu'ils sont seuls mais
la solitude ne m'a jamais paru est une
chose dramatique parce qu on est
tellement bien quand on est tout seul
vous il ya juste le perroquet qui vous
griffe un peu l'épaule le perroquet
maintenant il va bien parce qu'il a une
copine et je vous emmerde mois alors il
faut être capable dans la cuisine c'est
à ce que je disais
alors jorian nous allume faire de la
radio vous avez voulu faire de la télé
voulu réaliser des films j'ai voulu
faire des affaires d'une société de
tournage de films français aux états
unis et team america en france
vous avez voulu faire de la décoration
d'hôtel mais si vous aviez choisi d'être
que acteurs pensez pas qu'aujourd'hui
vous seriez un des premiers acteurs du
monde seulement un acteur parce que
c'est pas moi qui ai choisi d'être
acteur c'était pas mon c'était pas mon
truc moi je suis je voulais faire partie
du spectacle et surtout je voulais
écrire des choses comme des formes
demain donc dit mais qu'est ce que vous
regrettez le plus chevelu dire je
regrette simplement que pendant des
années on mais on n'est pas demandé
d'écrire les dialogues parce que j'étais
persuadé que je serai un bon dialoguiste
c'est le cas c'est sûr ils gardent le
disait légal d'études vrai qu'on dirait
mais les gens voulaient pas mais je dis
ça sans aigreur puisque j'ai fait
d'autres choses plus lucratives mais
pour moi acteurs c'est pas le truc
évidemment qui me passionne le plus fin
et si c'était à refaire vous referiez la
même chose de suspect refaire je
referais la même chose dans les grandes
lignes c'est dire que je met par exemple
je ferai beaucoup plus de choses dans la
décoration ou beaucoup plus de choses
dans l'urbanisme ou beaucoup plus de
choses dans des choses comme ça à
paraître lundi
pas trop dans la musique je passais bien
tu prends c'est vrai j'aurais adoré
travailler avec avec des urbanistes
j'aurais aimé partie du projet brasilia
tout ce facteur qua non pas tous aux
facteurs mais on est toujours acteur de
quelque chose dans une société qui nous
entoure
on a les mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
espérons que samuel subissent pas les
mouvements d'un fils samuel la subisse
pas le même sort quelques équipes et
bâtons t shirt samuel révéler le nombre
d'e-mails d'autres soins qui me sont
bien rangés tonnes est un body coach est
rigolo j'aime donner la définition jeu
voisins les yeux fermés impôts comment
ce site par un gros mot wet escroquerie
fondamentale ah mais oui c'est ça
attention amour oui imposture avez-vous
pensé ça oui non c'est là même dont
julie c'est la même chose que les impôts
il ya des gens qui peuvent pas avoir
bien qu'hier qualité de leurs oeuvres et
puis à des gens très riches qui peuvent
en avoir beaucoup parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup iota c'est pareil il ya des
gens qui peuvent avoir beaucoup de temps
9 alors ça si c'est que dans le dico il
ya me ça c'est un truc formidable il
faut saluer à alain raîche parce que
dans le nouveau petit robert
il a il il ya depuis longtemps un
certain nombre de deux mots ayant
notamment 9,9 étoffes et ça c'est quand
même il faut que les salles en europe ça
c'est une belle chose c'est
extraordinaire ça ce n'est pas dans le
dictionnaire de l'académie française
c'est pas dans le best seller les
académiciens sont jamais la teuf qui
n'ont jamais touché une moche ils ont
pas peur des coeurs battent en battant
battant vous dis tout le temps vous je
suis pas battant dès que ça devient un
peu dur je m'arrête
c'est vrai que moi je suis pas un fan de
l'escalier quand il ya un ascenseur
[Rires]
je peux en prendre chez vous maintenant
qui est très très bien c'est que le bar
vous le savez c'est ce que c'est un
clébard falloir un club marc c'est un
goût c'est artificiel apprenez à la
suite d'une intervention chirurgicale et
consistant à créer une petite poche sous
l'abdomen des fervents du nudisme pour
permettre de conserver leur carte de
crédit et quelques billets de banque sur
eux lorsqu'ils sont nus sur la plage
aurait toujours des phrases comme dans
le robert des exemples nus sur le sable
nous nous amusions à lutter soudain une
douleur fulgurante ne transperce a sans
le faire exprès mon compagnon de jeu
forcé sont plus dans mon club
[Applaudissements]
il est et il est pas mal soudain aussi
il est très très drôle aussi un du c1 du
ces c'est un jeune animal très
et sautillant mais oui qui se promène
dans la campagne
en faisant des cui cui miaou la raison
c'est un cas
[Musique]
vas-y jean yanne
comment ça va ya un moment on croirait
qu'on du mort la dernière fois vous êtes
venu il ya quoi il ya un nom pour un
livre déjà un
on a tout raconté les gens à part
commencer vos riches fassent ça tout de
suite pour me [ __ ] la paix non non je
le fais on voulait le faire oui toute
façon la dernière fois qu'il est venu on
va parler de votre vie drogue la
prostitution
oui puis on avait parlé de votre
aventure avec
on va pas recommencer on va passer à la
promo directement vous êtes prêts pour
faire des petites mains là j'étais bien
il faut pas dire ah non c'est pas bien
mais il faut rentrer dans le top 7 ha
oui pourquoi
pour faire la promotion d'un livre aux
éditions du cherche midi que j'ai écris
moi même et qui s'appelle
m exquis alors c'est un recueil de
pensées d'articles de texte
extraordinaire comme tout ce que vous
faites toute façon depuis que depuis que
je vous connais le ton est donné dès la
page de garde vous dites je n'ai plus
aucun propos dignes de confiance
j'ai tout dit j'ai menti à tout le monde
je ne sais plus ce que j'essaye qui
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair non
c'est pas la peine de dire rage j'ai
plongé dans mes souvenirs
ce que je dis est sincère j'ai jeune
j'aime ça je veux faire profiter le
monde de mes découvertes et de ma
connaissance jeudi je m'en fous surtout
ça vous va bien d'un coût de 90 balle
c'est aux éditions du cherche midi
voilà et c'est bientôt noël il n'y a pas
de raison
jeunes et des classes vous allez lire
les maximes que j'ai noté vous êtes
prêts oui page 14
l'amour est aveugle la preuve en le
faisant il ya des gens qui braille
[Applaudissements]
plasma l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
des convoyeurs de son
21 7 21 spéciales d'après cambronne ne
mâchait pas ses mots heureusement pour
lui
24 les bonnes femmes sont toutes les
mêmes elles nous insultent parce qu'on
arrive en retard et nous demandent
pourquoi on n'a pas appelé pour ne pas
se faire insulter deux fois gratuite
c'est quand on commence à payer des
pensions alimentaires qu'on se rend
compte à quel point moi ça passe vite
mais continue un peu
non ça va ils n'ont il faut leur en
laisser un peu ses pertes et lâche est
plus la brenne donc c'est pas ça mais
c'est parce que toujours un peu bébête
quand quand on est quand on raconte soi
même les trucs 87 87
je serais à la place des agriculteurs
qui dépose du fumier devant le mcdo je
me méfierais parce que les gérants vont
finir par croire qu'il s'agit d'une
livraison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]